We're only using single cubic gates here, so it's kind of trivial in a way, but in any case, gadgets such as this won't cause errors to
propagate. Now, any one of the individual gates in a gadget such as this could fail, and that will introduce
errors, but will always perform error correction immediately after every gadget. And as long as the error rate is
low enough, the error correcting code will correct those errors.
And like I said, this is always possible for polygates for every stabilizer code.
Although you do have to identify the right pattern of polygates in the gadgets to properly implement whatever logical poly operation you're going
for. For another example which does involve two cubic gates. This time we can consider transversal implementations
of C not gates. In particular, for every CSS code, we can always implement a C not gate
between two logical cubits by simply performing C not gates on corresponding pairs of physical
cubits. And this satisfies the condition of being transversal because each of these individual C not gates acts only
on a single cubit position within each code block. For example, the first C not gate acts only on the topmost cubit
within each code block. the second C not gates acts only on the second from top cubit and so
on. In this case, we could have a propagation of errors because C not gates propagate errors and there's no
way to prevent that. But the key is that the error propagation never happens within a single code block. For example,
an X error could occur on the top cubit of the top code block right before the gadget is performed and the first C not
within the gadget will propagate that error to the top cubit in the lower block. But the two resulting errors are
now in separate code blocks. So the error correction steps that take place after the gadget will be able to correct those errors individually because those
errors only affect a single cubit within each code block.
In contrast, if the error propagation happened inside of the same code block, then we might be in trouble because the
error propagation is then turning a lowway error into a higher way error that our code may not be able to handle.
This implementation doesn't work for nonCSS codes, but as long as we use a CSS code, we can always implement C not
gates transversely in this way. And for one more example, every
Clifford gate can be implemented transversely for the steam code. And in fact for any color code which is one of the really nice things about color
codes in particular a hatomar gate on a logical cubit can be implemented by performing hatamar gates individually on
each of the physical cubits and a logical sgate can be implemented not by an sgate on each cubit but rather by an
s dagger gate on each physical cubit. So the upshot is that transversal gate implementations are inherently
fault tolerant because they never propagate errors within a single code block which gives the error correction steps a fighting chance to correct
whatever errors are introduced or propagated by the gates used for these gadgets. So that's great and it's a
really simple way to build fault tolerant gadgets and there are different codes that allow for transversal implementations of different gates such
as T gates but unfortunately it's impossible for any non-trivial code to implement a
universal set of gates transversely which is a fact known as the eastern canel theorem in more technical terms what it
says is that as long as our code has distance at least two the set of gates that can be implemented transverse iversally will necessarily generate a
discrete set of operations up to a global phase and therefore this set isn't universal because universal gate
sets necessarily generate infinitely many operations. I won't explain the proof of this theorem which makes use of some
basic facts about lee groupoups and lee algebbras which are not prerequisites for this series. But the basic idea is
that infinite families of transversal operations can't possibly keep us inside of the code space because minuscule
differences in transversal operations are well approximated by lowweight poly operations which the code detects as
errors. So we're very happy when we can implement gates transversely. But for whatever code we choose, we know that we
will always have some gates that we can't implement this way. And so we need to look for alternative gadgets. By the
eastern canal theorem, we know that it's not possible to implement a universal set of quantum gates transversely even
for a meager distance 2 quantum error correcting code. So we need to find other ways to implement gates fall
tolerantly at least for some gates. One well-known way to do this is through the use of so-called magic
states. For the purposes of this discussion, let's recall the S and T gates which are
single cubic gates defined as is shown here on the screen. Let's also observe that first S is a Clifford operation
which follows from our definition of Clifford operations. But you can also check that conjugating a polymatrix by S always gives us plus or minus another
polyatrix. And second, T is not a Clifford operation. And in fact, if we combine T with Hadamard and Cot, both of
which are Clifford operations, we get a universal set of quantum gates. So we can't implement a T gate
using just Clifford operations and standard basis measurements alone. But we can in fact implement a Tate using
Clifford operations and standard basis measurements if in addition we have a copy of the state that's shown here on
the screen, which is the Tate applied to a plus state.
This state is called a magic state, although it's not unique in that regard.
The term magic state is also used to refer to different states that play a similar role to this one in variations of this whole
scheme. For instance, this circuit shown here does the job. And it's not too difficult to check
that. Here's the initial state with the top system on the right. And if we apply the C not gate and simplify, we get the
state that's shown here.
So if we measure the bottom cubit and get a zero which happens with probability 1/2, we don't perform the
escape and the output is t applied to s.
And if we measure one which also happens with probability 1/2 of course we do apply the escape and the net result is
that the output is again t applied to s. This isn't the only way to do this by the way. There are other similar looking
circuits that accomplish the same task but it is one way to do it.
This is a somewhat simplified example of something known as quantum gate teleportation, which I alluded to back in lesson 4, where teleportation is used